[Musique]
bonjour à tous cette semaine je vais
vous parler du film seven réalisé par
David Fincher en 1995 avec comme acteur
principaux Brad Pitt Morgan Freeman ou
encore Kevin Spacey l'histoire du film
c'est deux policiers qui sont en charge
d'une enquête sur un tueur psychopathe
qui planifie ses meurtres en fonction
des sept péchés capitaux il y a 7 péchés
capitaux la gourmandise
on touche à rien la paresse
la colère l'orgueil la luxure et l'envie
c'est demeure très faut s'attendre à ça
le film a rencontré un grand succès en
salle puisqu'il accumulé parce que 5
millions d'entrées en France moi ce que
je trouve très intéressant dans ce film
c'est la mise en scène parce que David
Fincher a réussi grâce à ce film imposé
sa mise en scène notamment par rapport
au temps qui se passe dans le film c'est
à dire que la pluie est omniprésente
dans le film ensuite la couleur est très
terne et très contrastée ce qui donne un
côté très glauque au film le film est à
des scènes qui sont très
impressionnantes qui peuvent être très
choquantes après
probablement un autre missile ils sont
victimes d'un jeu
aucune empreinte aucun témoin d'aucune
sorte c'est reparti la seule chose que
nous connaissons à son sujet c'est qu'il
est fou à lui ou le prix du péché
et la mort je vous conseille vraiment
d'aller le voir parce que ça peut être
très intéressant notamment de la mise en
scène
[Musique]